我作为一个至少长过三千颗多的游动机
从刀刀里口繁饭
反复复当养成现在这样
我用了将近十年的时间
但我现在发现其实掌握好方法的话
根本不需要这么久
我总结下来的是
互乎将代条要一起来
你少了每一个效果都不会有什么好
互乎我之前在讲的好多干货
能感兴就可以看我这个合级
不复品从皮膚入手
让我们两层不一掌握的风致
那一条从身体入手
最终的目的是让我们两层不一掌握的体制
今天就是分享我同那一条
然后我坚持了很久的一些硬食和生活习惯
第一点就是我做了日常硬食的调整
那我是胡鸦人
我就是喜欢吃肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉肉
所以我会通过别的硬食来做平衡
我经常会炸一些可以把我下
我可以养的书果汁做的日常带餐
像我前几年就刚刚分享了我的常用配方
像我里面加的其他自公布油
它里面的核心成分
就是可以帮我们的
我明感散
我在这样的硬食的平衡
只像我改作到整个人
就是很轻易通常
然后皮膚也没有之前那么发握了
这是我觉得非常有用的银汁调整
因为我之前的健康跟健奶街辣
要更适合我
第二个就是内服衡机
这个我真的是尝试好
我多么家里买的一堆
但知道后来我感觉最简单
高效的还是水餐服用一些
鱼肉来補充我们一咖啡
因为我们在日常吃的一些食品当中
大部分里面都有我们一咖啡
我们一咖啡有一旦伸过度
就会让我上家
尤其是我们游东西本身
这个皮色线它就比较活躍
所以很有容易会独赛
再加上一些不健康的银汁习惯
就好像容易长动
很多姐们应该都已经听过鱼油了
但是不知道的是
它除了可以帮我们把护管管
还可以帮我们轻动
押米感3可以来平衡
押米感6
稳定我们的皮膚状态
像我平时是比较少吃生海鱼的
所以鱼油对我来说就是右闪式
右右右
帮我稳定我的皮膚
但是有动机选鱼油要精神吃
对它就好像容易帮动
一定要选高纯度高纯量有任制的鱼油
它在喜欢和我一直坚持
在吃的就是这个
我最喜欢黑凋带鱼油
之前有很多姐们
我推荐鱼油
我都没有分享
因为当时我吃它还没有吃过28天
但是现在我吃它我已经吃三盒了
我真的很喜欢很喜欢
它效果很好
首先它这种小小的鱼
它就比一般的鱼油要好吞腐很多
不会卡在嗓的面下不去
而且它稳起来是巧克力味道的
你吃下去之后
它不会反与心味
这个对我来说就是很重要
我最爱它这一点
而且我把它也推荐
给我身边的很多朋友
大家丢的发贵都很好
它们也很爱这一点
我吃它什么感觉
就是我之前轻了闭口
如果没有轻干净
就很容易会爆成红种豆
但是现在就是会很平静的别掉
一份大多时候都是风平浪净的
一份油脂分
就是平衡的很多
我会有那么容易出现
外游内干的情况
像这一块它就是高纯度的
第一纯度的
它就容易有砸致
很容易激发爆豆
像这个是一天吃两个就好
两颗里面就有122号克导
它驱动的原理装是靠谱充阻量的
我们装3
和我们感觉维持平衡
帮我们渐上出油
让爆造的基底香气
里面还复材了虎美挑释
白利路城加清素
装就是靠这几位的房手提高
我们敌余的能力
而且它是这种黑色的帮助
更能保存于游的火性
我一般出门
就会把它撕了两颗
放在包里面
随一餐或者是饭后的池了
对于游它是指容性的
在我们常为里面有指防的时候
它的吸收会更好一点
第三点就是多运动
加速带线
我经常会去运动
不拿体验
然后一些运动
让自己爆汗
这样不仅能够出汗
又汗水把毛空里面
度不在的那些髒东西给清出来
让毛空变得透气
还可以让我们的皮膚循环
变得更快
叫我们脸上有时候会有一些红红黑黑的硬子
那运动在配合上户服品
它小的会更快
也行
不爱运动的姐妹
就可以通过泡澡
泡脚
真丧滩
让自己出汗
但是最好的运动
咱们游斗进
如果想要彻底的不长斗
那就一定要搭配上内条
只要真真的把身体内部调理健康
我们的皮膚才会越来越穩定
斗斗救得退取新的不长
才能彻底的
狗出取人身
那最后希望各位姐妹能够早日远离长斗的痛苦